то война на уровне Второй Мировой с
бомбардировками с обстрелами Мирного
населения в общество состоянии кипения
взгляды радикализируются
одновременно в принципе есть в
консолилированные какие-то позиции
против всего Российского естественные
против русского языка
поэтому Это наша норма и как мы будем
жить с этой нормой только время лечит
такие раны это ненависть останется на
Поколение или на два поколения какие
чувства выспитываете России сказать
одним словом в принципе наверное Гнев
очень стыдно и стыдно Даже за своей
российское происхождение рухнет ли
сейчас русской культуры подготом
нынешний российский политики она уже
рухнула
Андрій Юрійовичу 24 лютого цього року
яким воно було для вас 23-го
я саме готував борщ і приймав гостей і
одна гостя англійська письменниця Лілі
хайт залишилася в нас ночувати А о 5
ранку мене розбудили вибухи за вікном от
я підскочив я в принципі одразу зрозумів
що відбувається але не міг у це повірити
і майже годину стояв перед вікном і
дивився вниз на вулицю не знаю що я
хотів там побачити але спочатку не було
жодних ознак життя а потім Через хвилин
40 сусідка з будинку напроти вивела
собак погуляти о 6-й ранку прозвучало ще
два чи три вибухи Після цього ми з
дружиною пішли перевіряти якраз з Лілі
Хайд найближчим бомбосховище
у який момент ви зрозуміли чи повірили в
те що відбувається
уже коли почав дивитися новини в
інтернеті і зрозумів що бомбардували
одночасно десятки цілей в Україні
десятки міст не лише Київ тоді все стало
зрозуміло але звісно не було ясно що
буде далі тобто зрозуміло було що це
війна на рівні Другої Світової з
бомбардуваннями з обстрілами мирного
населення
і как Стекло і потім минуло півроку
війна все ще триває Як ваше життя
змінилося за ці пів року
я став
idp внутрішньо переміщеною особою ми на
другий день якраз із дружиною діти в цей
час на початку війни були у Львові з
друзями Ми спочатку виїхали у село через
день після початку війни потім поїхали
далі до Львова шукати дітей потім
переїхали до Ужгорода і ось з того часу
кілька місяців жили в Ужгороді нам жінка
літня пенсіонерка Незнайома дала ключ
від своєї квартири сама переїхала до
доньки сім'ї доньки Ми спостерігали ці
колони біженців які стояли в черзі
упродов необхідно кордоні зі Словаччиною
Ну в принципі все на наших очах
відбувалося
глазах происходило нещодавно вашому
колезі письменнику Юрію андруховичу
Скажімо так дісталося за спільний виступ
на одній сцені на літературному
фестивалі в Норвегії з російським
письменником Михайлом шишкіним ви можете
собі уявити виступати з письменниками з
Росії на одній сцені
по-перше шишки не з Росії а зі Швейцарії
по-друге я з ним уже виступав на одній
сцені під час війни і мені теж влетіло
Тож у принципі мені дуже знайома
ситуація з Юрієм андруховичем ну це не
єдина ситуація Борис Херсонський
Одеський письменник перебуває зараз в
Італії виступав разом з колишнім
радянським поетом Сергієм гандлевським
проти нього теж була хвиля ненависті це
нормально суспільство у стані кипіння
погляди радикалізуються водночас є якісь
консолідовані позиції проти всього
російського і природно проти російсь
російської мови тому це наша норма
як із цієї нормою жити
як жили в СРСР після війни з Німеччиною
зненавистю з терпінням з конфліктами Я
пам'ятаю що мені було 11 років у 1972
році коли треба було обирати у школі
іноземну мову англійську чи німецьку я
зразу сказав що ніколи не вивчатиму
німецьку тому що німці убили Мого діда
нині таких дітей в Україні чи їх батьків
чи дідів убили росіяни десятки тисяч ця
ненависть лишиться на покоління або на
два покоління
що робити з цим розломом між двома
такими близькими народами
тільки час гоїть такі рани У принципі
час залікував рани між Україною та
Німеччиною час загоїв рани між євреями і
Німеччиною тобто якщо Росія зміниться то
зміниться почастий і Україна і тоді
можна буде говорити що через років 30
ситуація нормалізується але передбачити
звісно точний момент цього процесу
неможливо оскільки я не бачу перспектив
змін громадської думки та політичних
настроїв у Росії найближчими роками ви
нещодавно сказали що зараз реальність
набагато страшніша ніж будь-який вигадки
і перейшли від художньої літератури до
документальної Тобто ви перейшли до
журналістики як ви вважаєте коли і за
яких умов ви повернетеся до Романів
художньої літератури Я не знаю Я хочу
повернутися насправді багато українських
письменників уже повернулися та пробують
писати прозу одночасно з есеїстикою з
публіцистикою я поки не можу тобто У
мене не виходить не получається А що має
статися щоб Ви повернулися до Романів
бо я боюся навіть на хвилину залишити
реальність коли письменник пише роман
він перебуває у двох світах одночасно у
вигаданому світі з вигаданими героями та
ситуаціями та в реальному тобто зараз
реальність спускає мене не отпускает
меня ми з вами говоримо зараз російською
мовою і ви пишете російською мовою це
далеко не само собою зрозуміле факт
зараз розмова російською мовою з
громадянами України між росіянами й
українцями багато хто відмовляється
говорити російською і переходять або на
українську або на англійську Як мову
міжнародного спілкування у вас немає
проблем з тим що ви говорите і пишете
російською
Ні у мене немає проблем у мене позиція У
принципі доволі тверда і всім відома Я
продовжую писати прозу російською мовою
есеїстику я пишу і українською і
англійською і російською але в принципі
Я російськомовне письменник в Україні в
Україні дедалі частіше і ширше
обговорюється питання обмеження
викладання російської літератури зокрема
в українських школах Ви відчуваєте
якийсь дискомфорт через те що в Україні
змінюється ставлення до російської мови
обмеження у шкільній програмі стосується
Того Чого Ми навчили у школі Тобто та
література яку мені в школі ніколи в
мене не викликала зацікавлення
найважливіше що діти і підлітки
читатимуть добровільно А це залежатиме
не лише від політики а від культурних
трендів та мабуть від якоїсь певної моди
тобто в принципі світовій бестселери
врешті-решт прийдуть в Україну і теж
диктуватимуть інтерес до себе зараз
цього не відбувається але колись це
станеться
що ви відчуваєте до Росії сказать одним
словом одним словом мабуть Гнів але
спокійно без криків без бажання бути
вікна просто соромно дуже соромно і
соромно навіть за своє російське
походження коли почалася війна я
мимохідь породіл що мої батьки померли
за два роки до війни і цього не застали
тому що я уявляю наскільки їм би було
боляче тобто вони не пережили початок
війни
ви живете зараз у Києві Ви відчуваєте
ненависть до Росії
ненависть Я відчуваю скрізь і не лише у
Києві Вона є і буде і залишиться при
цьому Київ продовжує говорити переважно
російською мовою хоча стала набагато
більше двомовної молоді Яка легко
переходить з російської на українську і
навпаки але ненависть є тобто в принципі
це мабуть найпоширеніша почуття щодо
Росії в Україні
у Німеччині зараз ЗМІ політики
обговорюють питання постачання німецьких
танків в Україну відправляти танки Марке
леопард чи ні німців стримує те що
німецька військова техніка наступальна у
вигляді танків буде на території України
направлена проти РФ що ви про це думаєте
Я думаю что любое оружие я гадаю
будь-яку зброю яку можна відправити в
Україну щоб Україна залишалася
незалежною державою і вижила треба
відправляти Німеччина не перебуває у
стані війни з Росією у Німеччині 20%
території Росія не відкусила війна в
Німеччині не триває вісім років як в
Україні ось тому так би мовити такі
німецькі сентименти історичні це
спокійний і трохи нервовий роздум а для
України діють зовсім інші критерії в
Україні потрібно вижити в Україні Путін
сказав що Україна не існує і не
існуватиме і самого слова Україна на
карті не існуватиме тому це питання
Стосується кожного громадянина України Я
хочу жити незалежній Україні я там
прожив 60 років свого життя там живуть
мої діти Я не хочу жити в Росії особливо
після всього того я і не збирався жити в
Росії але те що зараз відбувається щоб
прийшла російська влада російський
порядок на українську територію і знову
як у
1919-1921 роках почала перебудовувати
життя та робити з усіх радянських
громадян врятуй Бог такі перспективи
Напевно змусять половину населення
України виїхати із країни
чим закінчиться війна чи Скажімо так що
може її зупинити
призупинити її може смерть Путіна тоді
розпочнеться внутрішня боротьба за владу
у Кремлі швидше за все між чотирма
групами три групи у військових формах та
одна група російських олігархів які
єдині постраждалі від санкції реально і
далі все залежатиме від переможця з
іншого боку якщо російська армія заявить
що більше не може воювати якщо пройде
якась чистка генералів чи відставки якщо
Росія зрозуміє скільки вона втрачає
молодих чоловіків якщо вона змінить своє
ставлення до цієї війни тоді можливо
зупинка війни якісь переговори Але мені
важко собі уявити У принципі конкретну
дату таких подій таких событий наразі
переговори не особливо можливі ані з
одного ані з іншого боку обидві сторони
не налаштовані на переговори ідеться
Наскільки я розумію про те чи
вирішується все на потребує військовими
засобами
так як ви у цьому контексті оцінюєте
наступ ЗСУ у Харківській області
ну це не наступ це Контрнаступ це
взагалі-то звільнення частини території
це показує різний рівень мотивації
українських військ та російських військ
російський солдати воюють за гроші для
того щоб витратити ці гроші потрібно
залишитися живими вони звичайно
розуміють що якщо їх уб'ють батьки
куплять машину але вони однаково хочуть
жити і тому вгадаю вони не намагаються
на 100%, так би мовити зробити якийсь
подвиг вони хочуть вижити та заробити
гроші а в українців зовсім інша
мотивація це незалежність їхньої держави
це звільнення власної землі Я знаю людей
у яких батьки живуть на окупованій
території і вони пішли в армію і вони
хочуть звільнити Херсон де живуть батьки
Мого знайомого та Мелітополь і так далі
і Мелітополь і так далі
може бути з вашого я процитую вам уривок
з вашого інтерв'ю ТВ 10 років тому ви
сказали наступне Росія робить дуже
розумно виносячи наперед Імідж великої
російської культури що пом'якшує Імідж
невеликої російської політики це змушує
світ миритися з існуванням такої великої
різної талановитою держави з таким
дивним непередбачуваним народом та
урядом чи можна запитати зараз через 10
років чи впаде Російська культура під
гнітом нинішнього російської політики
вона вже впала пошукайте Переклади
німецькою мовою книг сучасних російських
письменників останніх кількох років
майже нічого не перекладається тому що
письменники почали дивитися всередину
Вони почали писати для Кремля грубо
кажучи вони для читача з тих хто
продовжує друкуватися це письменники
емігранти це Сорокін той же Шишкін зараз
поїхав ірпіньєв я не знаю чи видають
його в Ізраїлі якщо письменник
автомобільний то він не цікавий І
вільний письменники покидають чи вже
покинули Росію А ті хто залишаються
продовжують працювати на систему а отже
перестають бути письменниками перестають
бути цікавими те що класична музика
російська продовжує звучати у різних
концерних залах це не показник того що
Росія присутня це показник того що
частина російської культури стала
світовою але вона Таким чином
відірвалася тобто її вже навіть
інструменталізувати з політичної точки
зору не можна Пушкіна можна ось білборди
з пушкіним повісили з його цитатою про
те що Херсон - це чудове місто на півдні
Російської імперії будь ласка так би
мовити можна але мало З ким можна далі
так працювати з класиків із класиків що
дає вам у ці дні У ці тижні в останні
місяці надію що Україна виживе ви
повернетеся додому Що все це закінчиться
думаю рівень моралі і оптимізму в
українському суспільстві незважаючи на
рівень агресії на рівень ненависті те що
народ попри все продовжує жити як раніше
Тільки тепер це робиться із протесту
проти російської агресії і щоб довести
що Україна здатна подолати ті
катастрофічні проблеми які створює для
нас Росія
А в чому причина цього українського
оптимізму
причинами у різниці між ментальностями
російська колективна ментальність
налаштована на царя українська
індивідуалістична ментальність
налаштована на себе на свою родину на
свій сад і далі на своє село місто та
Країну У принципі в українців 40
мільйонів уявних країн в голові у Росії
один двоголовий орел і в даному випадку
в принципі оця Свобода яку відчуває в
собі українець де є величезну енергію
щоб захищати цю свободу щоб мати право
не любити власну владу власного
президента
Хмельницького чи Порошенка щоб мати свою
думку та мати право захищати її щоб
ніхто не міг тобі сказати що за це ти
підеш у в'язницю або що розповсюджуєш
фейки про українську армію в Україні це
неможливо тому коли є 200 індивідуумів
Вони завжди сильніші ніж дві роти
солдатів з колективним мисленням із
колективною безвідповідальністю
Дуже дякую прошу